how's it going brahs - beautiful today
I'm here where we're going to play piano
tiles 2 this is the third time we try
and record this video we're gonna
challenge each other you see was best
and whoever loses gets to tweet on the
other person's computer phone mechanism
yes I'll let you sorry
since you are there okay since Christmas
is in the air your one finger technique
which I'm not gonna question anymore
okay we'll see how far you get it's
pretty good you're not you're not
terrible I've seen you worse okay finish
pro in the game universe engage in what
is windy and stop oh my god
one punch might see one finger punch
Jesus 398 jingle bells my head is lay
back the whole screen is his way so how
many normal human beings I use two
fingers imagine Moe's are just playing
piano with one speaker what are you
doing haven't even started sir
you're calling me a basic [ __ ]
I'm in the pink section of the new car
can you stop doing seriously yeah okay
touch my boobs
all you want that's right you or you
have them ha ha ha okay I won round one
there are more rounds to be lost don't
worry about it
Wow let's do another song the suit
happen in the air because we're so close
yeah that pushed me away still the one
finger thing okay okay that's very oh
now you go in more fingers your nails is
so much taste in music it's realizing oh
my god before I even love that's really
where you knew I was gonna lose
interesting
let's do a really hard one okay the most
hardcore signs a long time yes happy
birthday to you happy birthday to you
that's pretty maybe someone's birthday
this is for everyone
Oh
oh my god thanks action I don't think
you think about you can okay
I'm gonna beat that sir
oh so you admit cheating okay yeah it's
first two three
its first two three yes right you like
prepare your phone and I was like okay
no okay we is - what is - what did you
what it's what one one one one
I can't we're doing a Giga you cheated
one you admitted to cheating one Oh
Oh fine that's pretty good with loving
Jesus Christ
damn okay one finger for some reason it
hurts
ah stop stop you can't stop em oh gee
did you have to realize oh my gosh I
technically long before anyone being
right okay good
I know your password whoa what the chain
Gina rosemary hi Felix
how do they know okay yeah well this is
fun
okay well check out piano tiles will
live a link to in description it's
really fun it's probably one of my
favorite okay that's it for now thanks
for watching as always
ah by the way Thank You cheetah mobile
for your financial support